my favorite is when they go oh it's  rigged it's such it's it's such a low IQ  thing to say it's such a stupid thing to  say  because if you hear Ben Astron who  fought him and listen if you fought him  I'm all ears but what it does is it  discredits Jake Paul's work well for the  most part the educated people and the  the people with a few more brain cells  we know this isn't staged but if you  keep care on that narrative and then you  guys fighting I don't know four months  Master Square Garden where we're gonna  do it and he were to beat you what do  you it looks terrible so either you're  in on it or you just learned that these  weren't stays and you get your ass beat  by a YouTuber